welcome to this video agent Fox Mulder
okay let's see I have played him before
him but I cannot remember anything one
game one game one win at least that is
my my line against this again this and
they have successfully forgotten
everything about it I've studied this
really a long time ago 10 years ago 12
years ago so some yeah it is played
somewhat like that at least I was quick
about it maybe Bishop f5 wasn't move
actually sending the route back yeah I'm
not sure how bad it is but I could have
I could have considered it at least
yeah black I can do various things here
he can do yeah can also go a six it's
not the best move ever but also not the
worst campus sugar 5 I can't send him
back am but is it doing much I don't
know let's let's go for that I was
thinking that it's Queen d3 and move or
is it like totally ridiculous it's close
to being ridiculous I guess yeah but
maybe I can really just take h7 now
looks to be a gem it really looks weird
yeah i was thinking i can take age 7
it's this naive Jack let's try I thought
g6 bishop I cannot I cannot take twice
there because I've rook Jade this is
totally totally bonkers my idea him this
is like total nonsense Bishop g6 root g8
I was wow I was totally forgetting that
I'm i have a have a i have a destroyed
structure yeah with with the jeep on on
a three wow how bad is that really
really bad oh my god is there some way
to get compensation for this Wow Bishop
age 6
Jim not really unbelievable I thought
actually look G 8am is much better but
ok that's enough yeah it's really enough
my idea is so bad am I I have totally
overlooked group g ade i was i was
simply not thinking that that I have
this damage pawn structure ok now we're
taking on g6
yeah it's still it's the useless him you
can just protect you six somehow and it
is some it is fine for him oh really hmm
okay if I take g6 now where is the where
is the catch I have ton of checks maybe
not a win but ton of checks oh come on
I'll take it this was probably not
working anyway it leads them at least
that continued somehow check here i am
so i will counter-attack on g6 bishop
see Silas also knows um subsea 7 was
actually stronger I am I couldn't play
whoop g3 because of the medium or the
routine yeah I don't know that was
really a an unbelievably bad idea ah
this Bishop f5 and Queen dirias was like
from the kindergarten or chess yeah
completely idiotic and not working at
all I come on buddy you can play
anything and it wins Queen f3 Queenie
for what not everything winds here
almost ah maybe not everything but close
its close okay yeah come on let's let's
be quick about it check
threaten some stuff I can go look at 7i
which is a pretty simple moved and shut
down should give him a technical win at
the end tonight f3 ruki ada weekend I
rookie six maybe yeah maybe rupee six
can irritate him a bit this Bishop is
not so great is some you can probably
also just push the deep horn somehow and
but ok let's let's see d3 rugby 6 ok
yeah this this makes it difficult now I
mean what are you doing with your with
your bishop now test no squares the bad
news is that you can even go d 3 ok even
d3 as possible or what's possible mmm
okay let's let's guard against that for
the moment and see what moves you can
what movie comes up with b5 I take a six
yeah i'm not i'm not even sure what this
position is I mean the evaluation isn't
this like starting to be okay for me
rook d 67 what is this I'm not mated
here right I can also try to to win
vporn I once to check made me I need to
be cautious time morning here and roop
this seven yeah I need to get get one
look off jack okay nice CSS was Lola is
the kind of game that I normally use
this black the opponent plays like a
complete [ __ ] and and I'm screwing it
up and here i was i was the the [ __ ] in
this in this story yeah bishop and his
sis idea is just so bad i really don't
know what what what to say him our wow
wow the computer actually think that
this is okay Wow with this okay cakes
and now takes why is this working
because of Bishop b5 oh wow yeah this is
this is like lattices is good okay I
understand and here i can take because
Jack this is a self bed Wow okay so Luke
takes c6 was actually possible to
justify this nonsense funny now I know I
didn't see any of that and even that I
can still take which I didn't see after
that I'm losing again I can take I
really didn't see the idea that we
should be five is all of a sudden I made
that set even seems to be playable for
white group takes c6 and here I'm just
lost track there was one pretty
yep case here yeah i don't know i have
to go here now it is a loss in any case
but somehow he got to a situation where
it wasn't that clear i know i don't know
how this happened here I think black is
totally winning certainly and yeah yeah
yeah yeah there is that you can you can
give up the the bishop he has to push
this deep horn home takes d3 and it is
it is promoting yeah something like that
was was the key to the whole thing and
here it's like minus one ya like it's
better but we are not talking about the
total a total loss anymore rucca three
you were still winning yeah yeah I would
quote what what to say I'm he screwed it
up I mean it can happen and I really
played very very badly thanks for
watching